hey guys glad to see you there before we
start the show we really do live reeds
before the show we started this last
week lotta with credit calm / mug club
for these entire two weeks $30 for every
signup is still going to Harvey relief I
know a lot of people have moved on down
the trail the news has changed but we
haven't all signups through this week
lotto fetter calm / mutt club we will
give $30 for Harvey relief specifically
to the Houston Food Bank and then one of
our sponsors they decided to pitch in
prepare with credit calm we've talked
about this for a long time $99 food kit
emergency food kit shipped free we're
not talking about it doesn't need to be
some crazy nuclear holocaust Skynet
doesn't need to come for you it's just
like we talked about it now floods they
could ice ice ice storms that we had in
Montreal earthquakes pays to be prepared
in this this instance $99 shipped to
your door free 30-day food supply they
will send a week's worth of food to
those in need in Houston so a lot of
credit calm / MOCA that's $30 every
membership will get you the numbers on
all of this once it's all tallied up
could be next week or the week after and
prepare with Crider calm if you were
wondering you were on the fence right
now's a good time to do it because it
goes to a really great cause and on with
the show here's the lead
so not gay Jared thinks that we're
taping an it parody with the Bernie
Sanders character because he brought it
up the pitchman he was really proud of
it I should say to begin with jared is
deathly afraid of clowns so he thinks
for shooting the it parody what he
doesn't know is that when he shows up to
shoot instead the studio lights will not
work and he will come face to face with
his worst fear it's Thursday okay
so touch me the joy gets in
[Applause]
let's go from 1 to 10 how scared were
you in hate clowns
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
that's called the hashtag stop Betsy
because hey I think that men who've
never committed a crime in their life
deserve due process no it's not Betsy
title nine now by the way I'm gonna show
this hashtag all day all day apparently
on campus just say the word rape say
just the first and the man's life should
be ruined for life self-loathing brawn
losing with me in video studios always
is Jared who is not gay follow him on
Twitter and not get you and me at s
Crowder with your thoughts your comments
your photoshop's I fulfill my
obligations during conclusions are we
good
Gerald is here at G Morgan Jr how are
you sir I'm doing well what's the one of
the day we have cake bread Chardonnay
because didn't have enough white hash
tag stop Gerald's gay tendencies so
listen we have Nigel Faraj on the show
today really excited I've done Faraj and
then we have we have Andrew tora tora
tora yeah a new tour but from gab but we
were going to have Jordan Peterson on he
is very sick so Arthur Rama's with
Jordan Peterson the guy I just did not
sound well and here's a really
appreciate as he called and he was
profusely apologetic he's always on time
some rooms on time when he's not
supposed to be on time and we're very
very very well have him on I think next
week but we will have Nigel Faraj on I'm
looking forward to that oh man ROG I'm a
fan can you believe the Betsy DeVos
thing it's one of those deals were you
know I wasn't a huge fan of Betsy DeVos
I didn't think she was the most
qualified for the job but now that
people are so and the left doesn't
understand like right now you comment
below I want to hear what you think
about this this noted feminist on
Twitter you can tell me what her name
was I can't I can't find the tweet right
now said women who have been victims of
sexual assault deserve to be heard
that's it it's like well we can play
back how about men deserve due process
now exactly I understand you can't just
say that I did something and then I'm
painted with it for the rest of my life
I run ironically all these SJW hipsters
on the Left are creating a lot of su w
or not su w history answers on their
right because they say Betsy DeVos
should be hung from the gallows and
you're like no actually I like you but
now now I have liked them
Betsy box wait 20 look into the story
this isn't it
all in our plans for the show tonight
now but can you imagine can you imagine
being that like mattress grow obviously
lacrosse team oh yeah
can you imagine being that guy with
mattress girl yeah that guy never raped
it by the way okay this is this was
actually turning point on the show where
we're all Christian conservatives but
was saying we don't want to we don't
want to offend people she was she was
requesting anal sex via text going all
crazy fatal attraction boiled pet rabbit
on the guy and when he decided to not
engage
she basically decided to accuse him of
rape can you imagine being that guy
being suspended not allowed to go to
your graduation and then some some
harlot walks anyway hey there's a broad
there with a mattress on her back oh
that's the girl who was requesting
sodomy from me oh she's on television
BYO our razor oh my life is ruined
anyway Josh texts that Betsy fuzzy will
talk about more in the news right now
dennis rodman I can now publicly
clippers and stop quote Trump should
just let let him handle Kim Jong Un's
this is actually what he requests the
boy so Kimbrel who don't know kim jong
than a dennis rodman have they've
actually become really close in recent
years with some saying that the former
NBA star has actually filled the void in
the wake there's speculation we don't
know for sure but it's filled the void
and the void in the wake of kim jong
father's passing yeah so really is just
another rebound what is this what does
Kim Jeong have to gain all this [ __ ]
I've always wondered it is does he need
a hood passes PC for a real thing North
Korea I don't really think all the ramen
have to get out of it do you think you
sitting around his buddies and like you
know what you know you're really cool
you'll be really cool be cool if someone
what could have if you could have been
like BFFs with Fidel Castro during the
Cuban Missile Crisis that'd be cool
right now it's this chance
you sure tirely sure I follow you but we
have to get Nigel's let's just keep
going through this five nurses in Denver
Denver Medical Center have been
suspended for ogling and deceased
patients genitals and then gossiping
about them that's how they were caught
bullying the least patients genitals and
gossiping about how impressive they were
come on that's just because of the fluid
retention said every male nurse that
Denver Medical
everyone knows it doubles when you did
that's not indicative it's not a fair
comparison replicate that in a fortunate
turn of events actually Denver Medical
Center's chief thoracic surgeon Jim
fondly known as dick little Wallis
committed suicide earlier today so these
guys because you imagine if you only
knew you're gonna be just a living
legend after your death oh my god for
your penis like a porn actor there's not
a lot of people that are gonna see it
most likely so yeah I guess the way we
want to go all right by the way Gerald
thinks it's Google it is Google I've
heard ah go it's yeah maybe but not my
bet yes that's right because you search
for words with goggle dummy okay Trevor
Noah explained today this is in the
Huffington Post we want to actually show
a clip because we've subjected to you
enough on this show but I do think we
have just an overlay of the story from
HuffPo Trevor Noah explained today to
Seth Meyers why Donald Trump is actually
a stand-up comedian
up next Trevor Noah explains why Trevor
Noah is a comedian I you know I hate
this dance to give it so it is lazy when
the left's just was no one on the road
is funny I think plenty of people on the
left are funny
I saw Jon Stewart stand up long before I
ever watched his show as some of the
Just for Laughs and I was young as a kid
I got to hang out I was very fortunate I
got to grow up around these amazing
comedians I actually think Stephen
Colbert can be pretty funny I think John
Oliver can be very funny even though I
think he's wrong Samantha be not not
amongst them sorry but um Trevor Noah as
an you've never been funny accidentally
name that really reference you can tweet
me at us Crowder but I haven't noticed
something with with late-night comedy
here and I just wanted to bring it up
before we get to something else up let's
let Seth Meyers see if you can spot it
for a very dark time in America but
there is also an unprecedented
opportunity to pull Democrats and
liberals together in a stand against the
hate and incompetence in Washington the
best way to do this is to get the people
who voted for you and the people who
voted for Bernie on the same page
this isn't the time to complain because
senator Woodstock didn't roll over for
you
hey have anything she helped make you a
better candidate
you know the candidate who beat Donald
Trump by three million votes yeah let me
ask you the devil look a late-night
comedy show to you and I'm not just
saying that because I understand that
maybe I don't share the same sense of
humor but they go a very long amount of
time for a comedy show that a single
joke none I tried watching a bunch of
late nights another night interested in
a series it was so hard to find actually
fine jokes anywhere in here they don't
write them anymore but listen we're very
open about our biases here on the show
we say listen this is our point of view
but I actually think that we prioritize
comedy entertainment on this show more
than a lot of these late-night shows and
they try to act as though they're just
going after the comedy that's what
bothers me is the lying about it and
here's what I don't know we've ever
really done this on this show Seth
Meyers isn't he's speaking directly to
Hillary Clinton advising on how to
mobilize the Democratic base that's
that's the problem and it's not that
these hosts just like just like happen
to be liberal that he's had Hillary
Clinton on she's yeah she's been on
Saturday Alive his show folks in
building I've been there I've been his
30 rocky MSNBC on one floor you have
Saturday live on another you have Seth
Meyers and one floor to another yeah
Hillary Clinton goes there often she
just turns the elevator into a Christmas
tree stop from every floor with fruit
baskets and he's telling her how to win
an election like it's it's not like you
just be able to separate the art from
the artist right like Sean Penn he's a
dick we get it but he's still one of the
greatest actors ever he's good you can
do that he's good and yes you're a pro
comedian right so you have a different
I'm an average Joe and that's not funny
I am his target market and that's not
funny at all yeah I know but you find
children's programs funny the issue is I
only have someone he laughs for sure
they mostly gonna knock a chair when he
poops himself by the way he did he did
at the clown Frank for those who knock a
Jared he pushed a little low
maybe a little I poop myself it was
mostly sweat in my pants
okay now just wipe my fairness and
fairness though to a good push-up or
pull up will also do the trick just
because of my condition chew a
toothpaste with no slack he's already
been rolled up he has no colon for
people who are tuning in for the first
time to the show I don't know why you
would not get jared has no cult i sec
say jared we deserve to be modest you
can show it you can show them when you
have it she looks like a stripper with a
c-section scar so Seth Meyers um but
really he's a political activist who's
out that he's using his this is what
it's not just that he's an artist his
only form of art right now with Seth
Meyers Trevor Noah Samantha B is using a
platform solely for political activism
and it's activism to people who are
their buddies it's not Seth Meyers just
saying hey gee I wish this would happen
on the left or hey you know what I
really would like to see this policy
he's literally using his camera to speak
directly to politicians with whom he
vacations in the Hamptons good thing no
one's watching good thing no good thing
no one's watching
alright speaking of which something else
here that we wanted to get to before we
bring uh Nigel Faraj let's let let's go
to the view here now we're going from
night time to morning and let's hear
what Joy Behar has to say see if you can
catch it I think media is supposed to
not report on the fact that 95% of what
he says is a lie well that's
that joy is that that that is a that is
you are doing exactly what we're talking
about in pushing a false narrative no
it's 95% of to see if this is true if
95% of what Donald Trump says is
patently false a lot let's go to our on
the field fact check reporter all right
on the field fact check reporter is that
correct that 95% of what Donald Trump
says is wrong balls okay bye-bye lot
Stephen thanks for expanding on it we
appreciate it can't afford the most
seasoned reporters so go worth every
penny though she brings up politifact
right so we'll focus today on PolitiFact
and Snopes both of them ten like we did
last week with with the Southern Poverty
Law Center for those who missed it go
watch the full show last week now why
PolitiFact and snow because Joy Behar
just a fact look look they just say it
hey will
she said deliver fact must be true she
said holiday bad in fact is in the name
why would they lie why would why would a
woman ever lie about rape why would they
lie logical like why okay you want me to
run down the list I mean I can think of
at least it does enough the top my head
now we'll focus on PolitiFact and Snopes
because just like Southern Poverty Law
Center YouTube users for defunding hate
hate speech Facebook and Google use
PolitiFact and Snopes to determine what
is fake news what is real so I think
actually we can bring this up I don't
think Gerald is seeing this yet this is
what Joy Behar was referencing so it's
just a sort of this totality of all of
their fact-checking Donald Trump where
she's taking that in there except okay
95% of what Donald Trump says is false
oh okay yeah so here are a few problems
with that you're going to be looking
down on my screen because it's hard for
me to remember all of this but for
example the in there you know you've
heard their lies damned lies and
statistics what statistics obviously if
you look at them if you understand how
to read them
be very important their middle but
they're very easy to manipulate
especially just create an umbrella
PolitiFact and most people are going
there to just see the green sticker of
true or false or mostly true or mostly
false and they proactively and Your
Honor I will lay out the case you decide
they proactively manipulate their
fact-checking let me show you some
examples Donald Trump made the following
three claims that politifact rated
untrue okay
claiming he did not support the Iraq war
they did six checks on that claims about
President Obama's birth certificate
listen he turned out he was wrong other
than that they fact checked that eight
times claims of large-scale voter fraud
by the way he's not necessarily wrong
about that five checks okay so for three
claims those are three claims
PolitiFact checked 19 times 19 untruth
that's more than through his Hallett
registers it's like a violation of
double jeopardy
yes nineteen times I don't remember
being wrong nineteen times I haven't
mrs. Bueller nine alright contrast that
okay Hillary Clinton some notable
Hillary Clinton claims as rated by
PolitiFact she claimed that she landed
in Bosnia under sniper fire that was
kind of a big one one fact check she
claimed she was in New York City on 9/11
that was never checked that was never
checked never fact check she claims she
the FBI was fine with her email use one
check so for three claims they rated
untrue PolitiFact rated donald trump
nineteen times versus two checks for
hillary clinton the same number of
claims can you see how that sir might
start manipulating some numbers so let's
get back to Donald trum and Hillary
Clinton because that's what she's mainly
using here some conflicts of interest
right off the bat PolitiFact is a
project funded by the Tampa Bay Times
repeatedly is endorsed Hillary Clinton
Snopes
they hire exclusively liberal employees
I mean you can see from their tweets
it's they've all nearly all actually
officially endorsed Hillary other okay
they've also been inaccurate many times
outside of the election one of my
favorites I love this
PolitiFact rated well don't laugh at
this because it's horrible it's horrible
it also is kind of funny PolitiFact
rated John Kerry's statement
I remember the fate of John Kerry's
statement that we got one hundred
percent of the chemical weapons out of
they rated it mostly true now in their
defense they didn't say entirely they
said mostly true but you know how we
know that it wasn't mope at all true
when Syria killed civilians and chemical
attacks earlier this year yeah they're
mostly dead that awkward kind of a
biggie whoops and they never get called
on this John Kerry just like these
people never get called on their bulk
crap
John Kerry lying to Joe Biden with Amy's
diner like Pat like blatantly false I
get it Donald Trump is not always a kid
sometimes he flat out and make stuff up
the difference is they called him on it
19 times Joe Biden makes up a place
that's been closed for 30 years he
nothing John Kerry lies about his
military nothing it's unbelievable and
it's like he can just keep saying this
stuff and saying it over and over again
by the way I don't know if you looked at
the church she was even wrong on her own
chart mostly true there was a percentage
it was actually mostly true that wasn't
categorized as false five percent was
labeled true mostly true someone's would
come on she's even messing with the data
in facts can't be can't facts can't be
bias by by definition but when it comes
to what they choose omits what they
choose to include can definitely be
biases matters like the people the
people who are combining the facts
trading the totality creating a picture
it's very easy to manipulate people
that's what we all say listen no we list
our references on screen sources go
ahead
delete do your research all right so
let's take that they've been inaccurate
chemical weapons Syria kind of a big one
let's take this back to Trump and
Clinton okay so Trump claims at the
national debt decreased by twelve
billion dollars in his first month okay
are you following along you've been like
why don't we have a frog in your throat
or something - yeah it's out now you've
been making out with Jordan Peterson all
right so PolitiFact confirmed that the
statement was true but they raided it is
mostly false
now follow me here because they didn't
think Trump deserved to take the credit
for that number that's incredible
float a fact rated Clinton's statement
in contrast about 17 intelligence
agencies concluding Russia was behind
the cyber attacks during the election as
true not even mostly true in contrast
with John Kerry's my word is my bond
mostly true it was a flight out true
we're not even a question
that Russia was behind the cyber attacks
they rated it true but they go on in
that very article to say that the 17
separate agencies did not independently
declare Russia the perpetrator behind
the attacks behind the hacks so if you
look at you see true you don't read the
fine print and then there was a lot of
backlash some would say I'm saying
someone say rightfully so the story they
issued this statement from political
effect Snopes they issued this it's at
17 intelligence organizations or for
question mark either way Russia
conclusion still valid that's convenient
a beacon of truth if I've ever seen it
by the way since that statement seems
like they're wrong about that also also
when it comes to Russia so the point
here if people haven't added this up is
that politifact is they're not
fact-checking they are they're actually
fulfilling the definition of editorial
ization so in Trump's case they thought
that he shouldn't take credit for the
numbers which has nothing to do with the
claim your your site's design is the
systems design is supposed to be being
able to determine whether the statement
itself was true or false very simple
they didn't like him taking credit so
they said false now in Hillary Clinton's
clay case they rated it as true because
even though they knew that the claim was
false they felt that the connection to
Russia which was not valid was still
valid so this is what's important for
people to note because again when when
Google when Facebook when YouTube when
they're using PolitiFact and Snopes
to determine fake news in the southern
poverty law center to determine hate
speech and really if you're any cut ben
Carson is a hate speaker it's important
because these actually serve as
foundational institutions in our country
that people assume have our best
interest at heart the people assume are
being truthful so when people use the
term fake news and I know it's been
diluted it it's lost a lot of meaning
this is what we're talking about a place
called politifact
blatantly manipulating data claims and
statistics to try and suit an agenda so
let's go back to see if we've gotten
this right with our on the field fact
check reporter
on the field fact it reporter would you
say that we are mostly correct in our
statements regarding politifact or
Snopes I just died a little on the
inside Stephen well I uh it almost seems
as though we should use that retainer
for another hire he's the man a few
words
yeah it's not a few words he's a man of
little value one could almost argue we
have Nigel Faraj coming up after the
break let's get to that oh I'm looking
forward to it
[Music]
you
whole-body friend with steven crowder
and not gay Jared learning basic
automobile maintenance is a very
rewarding skill to enjoy on those late
summer afternoons and a great way to
save yourself some money I'm a community
college student today we'll be learning
how to change your oil now that you have
the appropriate attire it's time to step
one ensure that you have the proper oil
and oil filter step 2 use a hefty jack
to lift your vehicle a few extra inches
off the ground
step 3 be sure to chalk your wheels as
safety is paramount if you don't have a
professional wheel chock any brick or
Rock will do we use yoga blocks then
it's as simple as draining your olive
oil into a pan swapping out the filter
and replacing it with plenty of 10w for
tea once you're finished crack open a
cold one and reward yourself for the
fact that you've learned a new skill and
save yourself some money
home body break with steven crowder and
not gay Jared sponsored by Mudd Club
[Music]
[Music]
all right I am so glad to have this next
kiss before I bring him I need to
provide context for some people out
there who may not appreciate him he is a
lot of nicknames the guy is is one of
the most iconic prop probably men of
this century politically and that's why
I'm so fascinated I know if people
realize it yet he is the Wizard of wit
he's that he's the king of quick
comebacks we know him as the English
gangster we hear in the show but you
know what show people they can see for
themselves false comparison I don't
think you compare these 800,000
youngsters brought here without any
knowledge of their own who are still
here I don't you can compare them to the
migrants who flooded into Europe in 2015
that's a false christs think too harsh
no it's not it's not a false comparison
because what happens is we're told we
have to be compassionate in order in one
case in Europe to be weak and allow
terrorists to come in and in the case of
America to ride roughshod through
sensible immigration rules today with
[Music]
if you haven't guessed Nigel Farage at
Nigel underscore Faraj mr. thrush thank
you so much for being here you are a
white whale we've wanted you forever
a couple of things I want you know I'm
fancying out here one thing that you've
shown I think in America we talk a lot
about civility and politics and that's
confused with agreeableness um you are
not shy at all in voicing your
disagreements sometimes with brilliant
insults by the way but you're still
friends with a lot of these folks you
still are civil why do you think that's
something you're able to do in Europe
and we can't get right in the States has
become so bitter so nasty and people do
it these days without a smile now look
you know what I attack my opponents
I generally tease them you know I mean
for example you know what I said about
mr. Van Rompuy he was president of
Europe you know who are you no one's
ever heard of you
you have the charisma of a damp rag and
the appearance of a load it's
interesting those that have attacked
million politics tend to amuse you know
real genuine horrible abuse I tease them
I do it with a smile and I'm nice to
them afterwards and I think that
actually is how democratic dialogue
should be conducted yeah absolutely we
watch that in apartment you know the
English parliamentary system I was
raised in Canada half Canadian so I used
to see that at play and I came to the
states and so how different it was but
it is true I thought maybe it was was
changing a little bit because a lot of
your political opposition you know the
left they use the go-to racist right mr.
Bregman Ola brexit is about racism you
know let's let's use this opportunity to
clarify that this sort of strain of
nationalism as people refer to it
national pride people assume that's
racism explain for them is it is it
based on melanin and skin or ideals
integrating with principles and Western
civilization
what is to do with actually nation ISM
call it nation ism not nationalism we
believe in nation state you know that's
why there are about two hundred and
thirty of them across the world
normality is people want to live in
nations and within those nations there
are different tribes different colors
different religions but people belong to
a block and they have a flag and allows
them and the government and they respect
it what is absolutely false in the case
of the European project particularly if
you say ginawa we've been a nation for a
thousand years totally independent not
conquered by anybody do you don't what
we're gonna do we're gonna give up our
rights of self-government give up our
Liberty and hand it over to a bunch of
elderly próximas
the adjectives in the advert elderly
little Larry Holmes the head pops back
all right speaking of which I'm sure you
follow this Sadiq Khan there we go half
headphones they're fixin Ellicott City
kanji was named in politician of the
year you've had some words for him he
doesn't agree on the statements you just
made is that another example of the
disconnect between media cuz we know
that in the States but is that happening
in the UK and the people the liberal
elites in the media the really big
divide actually is between the big
capital cities and the rest of the
country and it's exactly the same in
Ireland in the UK in France and in many
parts of America there is this kind of
big-city mindset that just seems to have
lost any sense of touch with reality or
normality they haven't got their feet on
the ground anymore that's the real
division and you know one of the great
skills that someone's gotta navigate
over the next few years is how we bring
the city and the country back together
again yeah well a lot of you learners in
the history of the United States and the
Electoral College for that very reason
you know you hear the left sort of
assaulted and try to say oh is to put
power
in the hands of slave trade they don't
know what they're talking about it's
because we didn't want just New York and
a couple of back then it would be New
York and Boston dictating the entire
policy range of the country so here's
something I will say Nigel you know I
was raised in Canada okay so in in
Quebec specifically sorry you know the
thing yes when it comes down to that
nobody likes the French the French don't
like the French once you get down to the
French it's just the French they like
the French Canadian in the
french-canadian the French from France
they just hate each other it's different
sects of French but there were no
conservatives there were liberals and
they were liberal separatist and there
was no Stephen Harper for the big
portion in my life so when I moved to
the state's it opened my eyes
politically to an entirely different
philosophy and I will say this Americans
um you were a first that's where you
know you were this lightning-rod because
they didn't think anyone like you
existed we were used to the Sadiq Khan's
what was that like you know being at the
center of it mr. brexit I don't just say
this to blow smoke because I'm insulted
plenty of guests as a not get you a well
knows um I mean we might it we could be
interviewing someone as I I con ik or as
impactful as Church Churchill the night
of brexit this has happened the whole
world's watching you gave your speech at
4:00 a.m. yeah what were you aware of
how big that was honest with you I've
been celebrating so hard for the freedom
hours it's amazing I was able to speak
because I on this journey 25 years ago
25 years ago I said to everybody around
me there's something fundamentally wrong
here it's gotta be thought I don't see
anybody in our color a political class
who sprang up the balls to stand up and
do this and I thought I'm gonna have a
go and everybody thought I've been
smoking something funny you know I must
have gone mad and so for me after a
quarter of a century I was just an
indescribable amazing feeling and then
to see that moment get picked up by so
many people who want liberty and freedom
and pride in Malaysian state in America
and without to help
the massive upset of Trump winning I
gotta tell you
2016 is a year it's gonna take some
beating yeah you with the celebrating
and then show up with the winning it's
just it is an absolute it is a nightmare
for the left
okay so here's something you just
brought up it's interesting to me you
have used Europe as or sort of its
policy shortcomings as a cautionary tale
for the United States you've warned it a
lot you're sort of seen as this Oracle
apples at this that's pretty rare first
States been right to use their country
on an international platform and say hey
listen this is where we got it wrong you
guys can avoid this usually you kind of
eddie haskill it you put on a good front
when you go to the UN you say we've done
everything right and then behind closed
doors you say oh we gotta fix this here
I'm what inspired you to do that and and
I know you talked about daca what are
the similarities there that's on your
most recent kind of string of
appearances let's do the small one first
dad you know what the left do is they
try to claim the moral high ground they
say look you know we're compassionate
we're nice we're fluffy we're lovely
it's for the good of mankind and if you
dare to criticize this you're some sort
of monstrous beast that belongs back
from centuries previously and and this
is what they did with the migrant crisis
coming across the Mediterranean and even
the fact that these guys in your country
were tagged the dreamers who can be the
ends dreamers they must all public
actually it's been used as a way you
know of allowing illegal immigration on
a massive massive scale no but on the
bigger question you know what made me
post brexit come to America firstly I've
spent most of my working life before
politics yeah I had a proper job once
how about that oh yeah it's a rarity for
American companies mostly Chicago based
so I think
to America for 30 years and we although
share a language what's interesting yes
of course there are cultural differences
between the USA and the UK but actually
actually we have a tremendous amount in
common and I think if you look back and
it's a bit a serious point a comedy show
but if you look back over the last 100
years and you see what our two countries
have achieved together the Liberty and
democracy it says to me with basically
on the same side and I thought that the
brexit message the message you can beat
the establishment the message something
can be done against these powerful
multinationals big banks big politics
big media I thought that message was one
that should be told in America because I
thought what people would see the
parallels and you know what I'm thrilled
cuz a lot of people did yes absolutely
and they went to the polls which were
rigged we it was amazing was it like a
direct parallel I will say I was one of
those people who said you know I would
like to see Donald Trump beat Hillary
Clinton at this point wasn't the biggest
fan of either I'll be honest but I said
I just I just don't see it we were wrong
I mean we were very surprised with
Michigan where we were broadcasting that
night at 7:00 or live stream we they
came in and the meltdown was absolutely
glorious to watch it is true you know
we've been incredible allies the United
States and Great Britain rough rocky
patch there in the 1700s not gonna lie
you kind of let your number-one draft
pick get away you built the bench and we
came back we came back good good point
that we have so much in common the
United States in in in England the UK
but that's what's most at risk of going
away if the left has their way the
commonalities that we have had that have
made both countries so great and I
wonder if that's an irony that's lost on
the left for wanting to find common
ground that common ground goes away if
we just go to the sort of multi cultural
internationalism
I think the nation-state is some kind of
relic I mean Hillary you know wanted
there to be it's a common market the
European Union on a big broader level so
so you've really got on the sort of
modern left you know the old left used
to perhaps believe in high taxation and
big trade union powers but the old left
certainly in my country were fiercely
patriotic they believed in the country
they just have a slightly different
vision to conservatives as to how it
should perhaps be run the new left want
to destroy and tear down history symbols
you know the nation but I have to tell
you I mean when I see the general robert
e lee who was probably the most liberal
of all the confederate come on yes
friend of Abraham Lincoln a man who
introduced a school to help educate the
slaves on his plantation or what I see
the left tearing down these symbols
attempting to rewrite history I know
that those of us who would regard
ourselves has been conservatives would
regard ourselves as being Patriot we
have to fight harder than ever for our
values because we're up against
something that is really incredibly
dangerous and I mean that well I I
completely agree and I say this
respectfully so follow me here I think
that you are the right guy at the right
time I think the left has given someone
like you a gift I don't think you would
deny that you're kind of a firebrand
and at one point it might have been
tougher to palette same thing with
President Donald Trump but when the left
out does themselves and parody right
they're saying well what's you know
Donald Trump came out said well what's
what's today rut robert e lee tomorrow
we get rid of washington everyone says
that's an absurd statement the very next
day let's get rid of Washington from
this Park
people are going you know what where
does it stop I mean that helped you that
gave you a wave to ride in on did you
recognize that beforehand or was it just
you know providential but I saw some big
mistakes and I saw Tony Blair
back in 2004 said to eight and then ten
former communist countries we're going
to have a complete open border with you
you know I wish these former communist
country as well but it led and I made a
big call on that I put my neck on the
line I was called all the mains under
the Sun for daring to do it but I was
proved right and I think in the end you
know you have to make some big calls to
be establishment and beat these people
and I think probably what the history
books will show is that I made some big
calls and I got them right and then
people thought you know what he may not
be quite as mad and bad as we thought
yeah absolutely and one thing to you
know effectively walking away from
obviously this incredibly powerful post
surprised a lot of people there aren't
many great leaders who've done that
George Washington is one of them which
is one of the reasons I've respected
more than anyone the guy who I want
leading me is the guy who doesn't want
the job I know you've explained it kind
of on on cable news and sometimes you
can't necessarily expound upon it
somebody what why that's it's so rare
what how did the lore of power not keep
you in I was afraid of the many years
for trading commodities and stuff like
that and do you know where do you get it
right you buy things at the bottom and
you sell it at the top having 25 years
assuming a completely impossible dream
being considered to be one of the
maddest craziest people that ever walked
the face of the earth considered a joke
cartoon for years as being a clown and
then you know what happened we stopped
the establishment we did him in maybe it
was a great moment to cash in my chips
and say thank you very much well just
like Rocky Marciano the only guy really
in modern times I can think of to leave
on top two things and I know you're busy
and you have to go do your wonderful
show people can follow you at Nigel
underscore Faraj 1 why did you not just
say aluminium you sit at the American
Way that's fascinating
I'm pandering you twits all right and
then finally well hopefully we'll have
him back I don't know after this
jean-claude young kanabi one of the most
powerful men in the EU I don't think you
two could be more polar opposites on
policy apparently you two get along well
enough again this goes back ending on
civility how does that work how do you
not just wring his neck but I understand
his view I think it's a
misinterpretation of history but he
holds it powerfully and he is a witty
amusing human being and the point about
genuine proper democratic process is you
should be able to be friends and have a
glass of wine with people you disagree
with that is what civility is all about
and you know what I'm now seeing but I
mentioned this earlier to you about the
new left and tearing down statues what
I'm now seeing is the new left what a
ban people from speaking what them no
platform at universities and colleges
want to close down in many cases the
very essence of of open free debates and
and Iran yoga you know whatever you know
and we are polar opposites now I
remember a couple months ago I was in
the European Parliament where I still am
by the way and you could turned up and a
little Chaplin and I said well there's
nobody here this morning to listen to us
he said oh no no no no no no he said
you're here you're the most important
person you're the only person here I
have a proper debate with that is how
democracy should work so I will go on
deploring and condemning everything
young adults in public but enjoying his
company in private he said you were the
most important person only he was
pandering you to it once he got me Hugo
thank you so much Nigel Faraj Nigel
underscore fudge thank you for being
with us sir thanks for taking the time
thank you thank us being great thank you
absolutely and the UK that was gonna say
[Music]
[Music]
well I'll be if it's uncle rabbit
Sullivan fallout shelter now it's even
worse than I'd anticipated private the
feminism virus is plagued half the globe
sir yes sir thank goodness I believe we
could write it out was there a food
supply from the sir
are you talking about that incredibly
affordable 30-day emergency food supply
kit from prepare with better calm $99
[ __ ] free that's the one sir good I
believe we can ride this out the key to
defeating the feminism virus is to let
their blood Sugar's drop to zero that
point don't be too frail to fight and
too emotional yes sir sir sir earlier
and once the ever female salary in
comparison to a male narrow strips of
the 77 cents on the dollar
[Music]
[Applause]
prepare with Crowder dot-com or call
eight eight eight four one one five one
five three 30-day food supply kit $99
ship they have pudding
[Music]
I don't know who clears their eyes this
way when you were still in the cartoons
like I I do a and I smile when I do it I
don't mean to but people laugh me
because I look so happy
yeah scratch corneas I actually do it
alright next guest we have Nigel Faraj
first know this this gentleman Jordan
Peterson was very sick we're going to
have actually this man on next week but
was gracious enough to come on this week
at the center of some controversy with a
website is gab dot AI for people who
don't know it is the only I guess I
don't want to say the only but certainly
the most prominent that I can think of
truly free speech oriented social media
platforms this is the guy who runs it
the founder of the feast Android or but
thank you for being with us sir happy to
be here thanks for having me thank you
so much well listen we know that this
very interview at the very least we'll
still be up at gab who knows where else
that's going down ok first off before we
get to some things that have happened in
the news tell people what gab is why
you've created it that way it paves the
way for the the controversy because
you've been called everything from a
neo-nazi to a white supremists all the
way back to neo-nazi I shouldn't say
everything it's still a pretty narrow
spectrum but it bounces back and forth
like pong right so we found a gap in
2016 and the idea was to create an
ad-free
social network that's defended
individual liberty the free flow of
information and of course freedom of
speech
I saw the censorship happening in
Silicon Valley ranted Lee and I also
lived and worked there and was a part of
the inner circle of inner circles and
knew that this the censorship strategy
was going to continue so I wanted to do
something about it so you created yet so
you were the inner inner circles the
Illuminati not that inner circle now but
I notice I didn't see you on our Tuesday
meetings see what what did you do
something about it have you have you
considered bitching on Twitter because I
heard that yes have you considered a
hashtag right yes so we that typically
doesn't work and it was also probably
going to get censored so so we started
this social network and we actually have
one of the most diverse startup teams
that at least I've ever seen so
we have myself my co-founder Akram who's
our lead engineer he's actually a Muslim
Turkish Kurd and that we have our chief
operating officer it'sif who is an
Indian and a practicing Hindu so it's
very difficult to paint us those two you
might have to separate them it's just
it's interesting that we're getting
paint it as a white supremacist website
when we have a very diverse team that's
from different backgrounds different
religions that are coming together and
saying listen we believe in the free
flow of information the free and open
web and the ability for everybody to
speak freely and that's been our mission
has been consistent from day one on that
fact yeah I know you've grown quite a
bit
so people obviously first off do you
consider yourself alt right where do you
line up politically because that's how
you've been presented in the media is a
de-facto Trump chill all right Pepe frog
guy correct the record yeah so we could
correct the record on that I I'm not all
right I'm not any you know I guess
traditional label I consider myself to
be a classical liberal I guess I'm very
libertarian in a lot of certain ways I
believe in the free market
up until the fact that I realized that
the free market is no longer free and
it's rigged especially when it comes to
mobile device hardware and software
distribution on app stores for example
there is a Thursday very clear duopoly
between face Apple and Google rather and
if if they don't want you in their game
then you're not allowed in their game
and there's nothing you can really do
about it so you know I think the left
always loves to say well if you don't
like the hate-speech rules if you don't
like the censorship on facebook on
twitter etc go build your own and that's
exactly what we did and now they're
saying you're not allowed to do that
you're not allowed to be on the App
Store right so let's get for people who
don't know you were kicked out of the
Android App Store and Apple right
correct well so Apple never approved us
in the first place and what they did is
they said that we had objectionable
content on our site and then what are
you sure about you were never approved
why do we book of not get you guys a
liner no wait wait so the thing with
that is is that you know there's plenty
of objectionable content on Twitter on
reddit on Facebook on tumblr etc lots of
gay pornography yes yes so they use
these very
ambiguous terms of service to
selectively enforce their guidelines and
that's a big problem because everybody
in Silicon Valley San Francisco is one
of the most liberally biased cities in
the world
so obviously you're gonna have a
workforce at these companies that has
that liberal bias when they're enforcing
these guidelines so right so you were
not approved in Apple and then you were
kicked out of the Android store so I'm I
want to so let's let's go to that what
reason did they give to you by the way
if people just tuning in gaba-a i for
kicking you out so they said that we
were breaking their hate speech policies
and the reality is is that there's hate
speech anywhere on the web anywhere you
go that there are two more people
chances are you gonna come across hate
speech so again they're selectively
enforcing and deciding who can actually
participate in the free market who can't
now obviously they're gonna argue well
you can still access gab from a mobile
you know browser but it's not the same
as an app you know tell that to
consumers who emailed us a hundred times
a day asking where our app is right
right that that's that's a real problem
for distribution it's it's harmed our
business and it's anti-competitive
antitrust behavior so that's that's key
because I don't I hate to keep integrate
but it's key because I can see people
making comments and most people are
making the wrong comments they don't
understand what the First Amendment is
they don't understand what's protected
and what you were talking about here is
something that is anti-competitive it is
potentially a violation we're not
lawyers we're not saying it is we're not
declaring it is but we're talking about
antitrust laws that's your issue right
correct and we've actually launched a
legal fund and we are currently
exploring all options from every angle
of this whether it's the First Amendment
angle the antitrust angle the
anti-competitive angle there's a lot of
different issues that are happening here
and we're not the only ones that are
suing Google for antitrust behavior they
were just find in the EU I think it was
2.5 billion dollars for that one's done
that one stung them okay so speaking
which we have we have a Google store
we're talking about now what happened
with the hosting right now you so the
right yeah yeah yeah this this is
unprecedented and this is this really
worries me about the future of the free
and open web so
we had our domain registrar contact us
earlier this week and they said that we
needed to remove an individual post from
an individual user that happened to be a
mean that was breaking our guidelines so
our guidelines are pretty clear right we
allow free speech within the lawful
limitations and we have some simple
guidelines around tagging stuff that
probably shouldn't be viewed at work as
not-safe-for-work so things like porn
and obscene content and I reviewed the
post and the post was indeed breaking
our guidelines it wasn't something I was
going to ban the person for it wasn't
something I was going to make a big deal
out of but it did need to be tied does
not say for work so it was technically a
violation of our guidelines but it
wasn't something that I would expect a
registrar who threatened us to literally
remove and seize our domain if we don't
censor this post from this individual
user within 48 hours
yeah that type of demand is really
unprecedented I've never heard of
anything like this now obviously if it
was something illegal if it was breaking
the law that would be understandable if
it was a copyright claim all of these
things are very common-sense and
understandable but this was I don't want
to say common sense because I think I
think especially if you look at your
your your rules they actually follow the
law so copyright you guys follow
actually recruiting for Isis or
something wouldn't be allowed that calls
to violence and of course a Saran can be
proven as libel and slander that is not
allowed either which by the way
ironically is allowed on Twitter you can
find fake memes of me with swastikas
tattooed to my neck saying gasps the
Jews I said hey this is a this is
actually a lie you're like it's not a
violation so I want to be clear you know
people would say common sense but you
guys are very clear in outlining it and
I think when a lot of I know you're not
but some alt-right media covers it they
don't they need to Zone in on that man
because that is so important you guys do
have parameters and it's not a moving
target and that's what's different well
and that's the thing too is we actually
cite individual Supreme Court precedent
in our guidelines as well like we are
using the the First Amendment and
rulings on the First Amendment to shape
and form our guidelines and obviously we
don't want to allow any illegal activity
like we want free and open discourse
because when you allow free and open
discourse in the exchange
ideas it helps to actually prevent that
illegal activity from happening because
when people can't express themselves
when people are being shut up across the
internet when people are being no
platformed off the internet and
unperceived off the internet now they're
more likely to get down that road of
violence and other illegal activity and
go to the dark web where there is more
illegal activity so by allowing you know
free speech and free expression and the
idea ability to exchange all ideas and
ideologies no matter how much they
trigger certain people you know that is
something that is the the the better
route in my opinion than violence or
illegal activity it's funny I use the
word trigger because ironically the word
trigger has become a trigger they hear
the word Audry's now here's the problem
too is having a good friend you know who
works in psychology psychiatry trigger
is an actual medical term you know
someone with PTSD that can trigger and
I'm like well listen let's not lump that
in some guy coming back who's having
flashbacks to Nam where his friend got
his nards blown off like trigger is a
legitimate term it might trigger a
flashback you're just a [ __ ] who goes
to a state college so we have we were
talk about this right during the break
YouTube has restricted mode now we have
been working with YouTube I will say
they've been very gracious they've
helped with some issues but the issue
that we keep running into is restricted
mode nage Jared knows this we have 640
something videos and they reached out
and said okay well which videos you
think are unfairly restricted I said
well only like 19 are not restricted so
every conservative video I said but here
are some examples
Jordan Peterson literally sitting down
and just conducting a personality test
me doing a long-form interview with
Dennis Dennis Prager asking about human
nature are humans by nature good or are
they sinful this is a an observant Jew
what else do we have
yeah philosophy I mean these are these
are issues where these people wouldn't
be on the show if it was even profane
you know at that point and they they
just responded thank you this is helpful
that that's the issues it's a moving
target and businesses have the right to
do what they want obviously but they
don't have the right to lie about it and
and that's the issue that I see coming
up a lot and you know I see you guys
game and some seems so we have to get
going pretty soon but what's next for
Gabby I again for people who are looking
to get that AI right so right now the
Internet is completely centralized in
control by no more than a handful of
people there are day keeper
at the hosting level the DDoS protection
level payment processing as we've
learned this week domain registrar's so
we if we have to we are going to rebuild
all of that we will rebuild the internet
from the ground up to be pro free speech
and then decentralize the control over
it with things like blockchain
technology for example we're going to be
launching our own ICO
and minting our own utility token so
that our users can actually exchange
value back and forth with one another on
the site so that is really the next
level for us is getting decentralized
and getting it built on top of the
blockchain technology so that we don't
have to worry we could censorship proof
the Internet and defend and protect free
speech and the open web absolutely and
just so just so funny just like Nigel
just talking about who could who could
be against dreamers good all these big
giant corporations that people protect
their monopolies let's make a foot in
the door well here's the thing about net
neutrality is what what is the purpose
of net neutrality like that's that's a
problem in and of itself but I don't
know how their virtuous signaling about
this meanwhile the internet is in the
control of those five different services
that I just mentioned so yeah those
those gate keepers decide guess what
you're not allowed to have your domain
or you're not allowed to host or you're
not allowed to payment process rather
you operate you can't it's impossible
right they're bitching about ISPs it's
kind of like when Jennifer went after
Sinclair he's like Sinclair's one of the
biggest broadcasting groups they could
have them an Opel it's like you're your
parent company time orders merging with
AT&T you arrogant English ass alright
right Andrew Torborg AB dot a I please
do keep us posted man and we appreciate
what you're doing out there and you have
permission to grab grab this video when
it might be the only place that food
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god brother
I always knew this day would come
Sullivan sir yes sir
thank God we prepared with prepare with
Crowder calm sir yes sir you a full
30-day supply sir none in dollars
shipped free I know that I'm a general
don't you think I know that course sir
you bet to prepare with credit concert
that's right Sullivan I invented prepare
with credit calm let's go through the
checklist for 30 days food supply where
does it get from compared with better
calm sir check one two three one
generator ship sir
lady magazines sir yes sir toilet paper
stole them
toilet paper sir
I use the last of the supply last week
forgot to restock sir good luck general
sir
you know I've IBS
prepare with browner dot-com for call
eight eight eight four one one five one
five three 30-day food supply kit $99
ship free they have pudding viewer
discretion is advised
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
feminist cops is filmed on location with
the brave strong women of law
enforcement
all suspects are innocent until proven
guilty in a court of law so nine times
out of ten if someone's acting
suspicious they're probably sir I need
to ask you to pick up that bottle that
bottle over there
won't you don't you pick yourself up my
beer girl no just pick up the bottle no
just you come over here I'm here go in
your fine ass over here
no just can you pick up the bottle
please no just come over here girl I
talk over here come on no just just the
bottle pick it up
we'll talk about the bottle when you
come over here we can play cops and
robbers if you know what I mean
don't girl I'm a lesbian
bad girl bad girl what you gonna do what
you gonna do
[Music]
[Music]
there
just do it because knocking Jared can't
thank you so much Andrew
Nigel Faraj I think we'll have him back
on the show yes his his his press press
secretary I don't know whoever it is
said I enjoyed the show very much she
seemed like you have a good time
people seem surprised this is gonna be
you doing an impression of Nigel now
listen listen PolitiFact
jeff says it's politics in fact cesspit
gosh Joy Behar I've talked about this
before there are people with whom he
disagrees interests and it she's still
mind-numbingly stupid like I've seen
people sit across the table from her and
they're not even having the same
conversation she's insufferable chill
Hoss I can actually that dead that claim
is it I could I could sit there and
everything we talked about today I could
sit there and said well you know
actually that claim was kind of
incorrect because they took the same
three claims of Donald Trump facts at
some 19 times versus three claims from
Hillary Clinton they only fact-checked
him twice and I'd say what late I was so
bad this week I'll wash it as well as
things were you know what's that been so
bad you have to wonder was it ever good
oh that's kind of like I had that with
with Mike Myers in the Love Guru it was
so bad I didn't even want to go back and
watch Austin Powers yeah that's going on
oh like Ninja Turtles too you just wish
you would have left up there something
that you know in just going through this
show that I wanted to talk about I think
the greatest lie that we've ever been
told I guess as a society period but
particularly as it comes from the left
the entertainment tree because been
talking about that quite a bit the
entertainment industry sort of the media
complex this lie is just just to be
yourself
the left doesn't they've been telling us
that since we were little kids sesame
just just be yourself
except they actually they don't want you
to be yourself they assume you to be
just like them and when you're not they
demand that you be just like them so
Seth Meyers
let me explain he is some the
presumption he goes yes we're going
through a very dark time in America um
no maybe I don't agree with you maybe a
lot of us thought it was a pretty dark
time in the United States when Barack
Obama was president the executive
actions in an unprecedented way
we were looking at unbelievable spending
that we had never seen in this country
before white houses looked at a guy who
had smoked crack was a domestic
terrorist we thought that was a dark
spell so they assumed see what you agree
with him and then if you don't agree
with him they demand that you be like
them so it's just like Google and Apple
pulling gab wife or not here's what's so
crazy about that story it we've gotten
to the point from the left where you
know be yourself we're not only so far
from that but they're pulling a platform
from the Google and App Store for not
censoring other people it's no longer
for something you've done it's you
haven't effectively enforced our
opinions enough on somebody else on your
site therefore we're gonna punish you
even they're fact-checking they'll find
a way to falsely label a conservative
three times the amounts that of a
liberal for the same number of claims be
yourself okay well you know what I think
that if we work well that's false
nineteen times she said she was she said
she was in New York at nine eleven we're
just your nineteen times more bet Ron
nineteen times more wrong is more than
the not nineteen she said she was there
at nine eleven tomato tomahto corruption
school right now across the country and
I get the cuz again we get a lot of
emails from college kids diversity
charlatans you see they she's with a
protester telling everyone just be just
be yourself be yourself you just listen
you will find it if you are just true to
yourself true to what you believe that
great things of then hashtag stop that's
a and if you bring up well how about due
process they expel you or call you a
sexist or racist just black people they
just think need to have they haven't had
their voice heard they haven't we need
there's because of systemic I had a
voice heard enough a black conservative
speaks up they're an Uncle Tom it's not
and I want to clarify you it's not about
hypocrisy because we hear that a lot
from the right where they just go it's
hypocritical and then in a net you know
this is kind of a concern the concern
the conservative if the Reverend
upstairs they wouldn't have anything yes
if it weren't for double standards I'd
be out of a job
so it's if this is not about hypocrisy
everyone's a hypocrite as a matter of
fact I think it's far easier to point
out conservatives as moral hypocrites
it's like pointing is someone who missed
their high jump when you're eating
popcorn in the stands I get it having
any standards is going to open you up to
a level of hypocrisy that just can't be
understood by someone with no standards
okay so it's not just about hypocrisy
it's about a systemic lie that the left
is perpetrated on the American public
since we were toddlers watching Sesame
Street and they had no the most
important thing is they had no intention
of fulfilling this is not a lie where
they've kind of they've gotten off the
beam where they've lost themselves you
lost yourself no that's not what's
happened the left never wanted you to be
yourself why are you going left and
right because I'm trying to make a point
here dummy look labels shut up okay
they've always wanted you to be a part
of their blob like massive people and if
you're not they'll destroy you and the
only way the left can destroy you I want
to be yourself cut is with their numbers
the left is the political ideology of
cowards who travel with their chain
gangs because it makes them feel tough
and ironically on the flip side look at
gab look at Nigel Faraj look at people
like who take take your pick take not
gay Jared he's a guy who breaks some
molds you can take Nigel you can take
Donald Trump whether you agree with it
or not
those on the right the greatest
strengths that conservatives have is
that of people being themselves it's the
only way our ideology works it's it's
why we have actually we have an
unbelievably intellectually diverse
audience just look at the comments
section you know I'd love to see in the
comments section below whether you're in
CR to be mullah member or YouTube what
do you can see yourself libertarian
conservative populist all right
independent let us know we better in
events for the most people that came up
to us wanting sign t-shirts or one in a
picture we're people that left we
consider a marginalized group yes
yeah very consistently very can as a
matter of fact it will so because I tend
to be the moment the most ardent fans
yeah because they're probably the most
marginalised group ironically by the
left because they have no friends on the
left because they haven't fallen into
the be yourself but just be yourself
within just get beer but dump don't be
beyond yourself needs to be be in our
box Sally just be yourself
Sally be happy over the penis yes
so we it's why it's why it is our
greatest strength on the right it's why
we have an unbelievably intellectually
diverse group of fans who they all all
of us listen they they hone and sharpen
each other you hunt and sharpen us I
want you to be yourself I want you to
question me I certainly want you to
question anything not kids here it says
I want you to choose your own path
unlike the left because I'm like the
left it operates as a gang I know that
when you are your true self when you
when you actually go out and be yourself
when you pave your own path
that's how greatness occurs and that's
the fundamental difference in the world
you because unlike the left who when and
if you become successful they're right
there to yank you're right back and be
yourself with the rest of us I want you
to be as unique as honest and successful
as possible I want you to be yourself so
that you can be great because you know
what ironically I understand that when
one individual is great we all benefit
Hey
doesn't take a village takes a few great
people let's undergird them go forward
this week be yourself and be great see
you next week
[Music]